yeah chase Stokes and Madeline Klein
just made their romance Instagram
official
it's really cool on Sunday the outer
Bank stars who play John B and Sarah
Cameron on the Netflix drama hit the
sand for a beach date and Chase shared a
pair of pics from the outing the caption
cats out of the bag the cat being that
they're totes together chases 22 year
old leading lady slid into the comments
writing topper punching the air right
now which is a reference to her
on-screen boyfriend in Outer Banks she
also wrote I've fallen and I can't get
up ah their co-star Jonathan Davis also
commented on the pic writing well it's
about time why do I get the feeling I'm
not the first girl you brought here
chase and Madeleine who are first
romantically linked back in April are
also dating on screen in the mystery
drama back in April before the cat was
out of the bag the lovebirds played coy
when et ask them about their rumored
romance I have to ask about the obvious
are you guys quarantined together so we
actually decided it's myself Maddie
Rudy and drew and then one of our other
friends Elaine we've all quarantined
together we made a giant fort in the
living room we've been kind of every
night cooking meals together so we're
kind of making the best out of it yeah
it's sort of a little party so yeah but
it's been nice it's been nice to have
company and have people around I kind of
go for the people who are gonna want to
know are you guys single
are you dating right now we kind of just
make sure you fans are really gonna
freak out now when they watch this yeah
let them think about it
are you guys ready for people to ship
you two together because we know with
Netflix why it shows that tends to
happen no I mean I think the thing is is
with this quarantine going on right now
like it's so hard to actually grasp
reality we can't stand yeah please you
and they dished on the show's season 1
cliffhanger which saw John B and Sarah
fighting for their lives
in the middle of the ocean I mean it's
it's cool because obviously you know
depending on what happens it leaves the
entire world without her bangs up to you
know what could happen next which i
think is fun for not just us as actors
along an opportunity to kind of explore
you know what could be and obviously we
know where we're going and now so we
know where the gold is so I think it's
an exciting time to kind of give it to
the world and say that we're champions
that we're really gonna get into now if
you thought it was dark and dirty just
then but it's gonna get real yeah
[Music]